el kremlin advirtió sobre las
consecuencias más indeseables y
finlandia y suecia deciden entrar en la
otan los dos países tradicionalmente
neutrales dijeron que están considerando
solicitar su ingreso
la primera ministra finlandesa indicó
que su gobierno lo decidirá en las
próximas semanas
también creo que tenemos que tomar la
decisión por nosotros mismos no dejar
que el miedo influya en nuestras
elecciones
finlandia luchó contra los invasores
soviéticos en la segunda guerra mundial
pero desde entonces no se ha alineado
militarmente sin embargo desde que su
vecino ruso invadió ucrania la cláusula
de defensa mutua de la otan que dice que
la alianza militar liderada por eeuu
considera que un ataque a un miembro es
un ataque a todos parece cada vez más
atractiva y antes de estar en contra
entrar en la otan pero hoy creo que es
una opción razonable
creo que finlandia debe ser autónoma por
lo que creo que podemos arreglarnos las
solos el socio cercano de helsinki
estocolmo tiene sus dudas no ha luchado
en una guerra desde 1814 pero una
reciente encuesta publicó que casi el
60% de los desearían unirse al otan si
finlandia lo hace no hemos molestado a
nadie durante 200 años ha sido muy bueno
para nosotros
creo que deberíamos hacer exactamente lo
mismo que hace finlandia es finlandia a
medida que aumenta la probabilidad de la
adhesión de ambos países el ex
presidente ruso dmitri mes de haber
advertido que moscú desplegaría misiles
hipersónicos en kaliningrado moscú habló
en el 2018 de poner armas nucleares en
el enclave ruso a menos de 800
kilómetros de helsinki y estocolmo